There’s an ancient Arabic legend about a
shapeshifter that can take the form of any
animal.
They can also appear as a living column of
smoke or dust, or a giant human— and have
also been known to live trapped in a bottle.
Jinn are genies - ancient creatures believed
to occupy the space between celestial and
terrestrial worlds.
Not quite monsters, not quite humans, and
not quite celestial beings, the jinn are something
different.
But for many people, the genie is just some
guy in a lamp who can give you three wishes.
A way for you to get what you want without
having to work for it.
Not only is that not even close to the original
versions of the jinn, it dismisses the immense
power these beings possess.
The jinn are a species all their own, more
powerful than humans, and more meaningful
than pop culture would have us believe.
[Monstrum intro.]
Crafted from prehistoric fires, long before
humans, Jinn are neither wholly earthly nor
wholly spiritual.
They require food to live, are subject to
lust and other human passions, and can die,
although they live naturally for thousands
of years.
Jinn can see humans and interfere in their
lives.
Humans can only see a jinni if it takes a
form that allows itself to be seen, which
is rare.
They can move through walls and travel great
distances quickly, shapeshifting into all
kinds of animals and can appear as smoke.
Sometimes the appearance of a jinni is preceded
by an earthquake or a storm.
In ancient Arabic cultures, jinn were worshipped
for their capacity to make legendary weapons
and supposed ability to encourage fertile
crops.
These pre-Islamic accounts of jinn also claimed
a jinni could take on a human form and and
have children with them.
These offspring were often seers who could
communicate with their jinn relatives as well
as with the divine.
These half-jinn children were advisors and
consultants of religious matters.
They helped find lost animals, gave and removed
curses, and settled personal disputes.
Islamic narratives heavily influenced the
perception of jinn and their characteristics.
The Qur’an explicitly mentions there are
three types of spiritual beings: angels, demons,
and jinn.
That text also states jinn were created before
humans and are intelligent beings with free
will, formed from “smokeless fire” and
“scorching winds.”
In Islamic tradition, people made from clay
occupy the material realm of Earth, while
angels occupy the celestial realm of light.
It’s said that jinn, being made from fire,
reside in a realm between the material and
celestial—called the intermediate realm.
A particular story in the Qur’an tells of
an encounter between the prophet Muhammad
and a crowd of jinn.
This tale describes the jinn as “men, tall
as lances, completely wrapped in their mantles
from their feet up” who seem to be composed
of “blackness.”
Interestingly, the 55th chapter of the Qur’an
is written in duel form for both humans and
jinn.
It describes Jinn as practitioners of religion,
including Islam, who are believed to have
the same religious responsibilities as humans.
Medieval Muslim scholars believed the jinn
were susceptible to fiery temperaments because
they were composed of fire.
So jinn could either be good or evil.
The evil jinn were said to enter into the
bodies of humans, causing madness, injury,
or death—an idea that pre-Islamic communities
shared as well.
Human and jinn interactions weren’t always
negative—stories of love affairs between
jinn and humans were popular in the Medieval
period.
One of the most famous interactions between
jinn and humans occur in one of the world’s
most popular texts— The Thousand and One
Nights.
Scholars argue the famous collection of stories
takes its inspiration from a number of sources
including Indo-Persian and Greek traditions
as well as Arabic-Islamic ones.
One thing for certain is that although a 9th-century
fragment and a 14th -century manuscript of
The Thousand and One Nights have been found,
there still no conclusive source.
Since jinn figure heavily in various stories,
we can assume that some aspects of these creatures
exist across many cultural histories.
With each translation and variation of the
text, older and newer tales were added and
subtracted regularly, but the jinn appear
in all known editions.
One significant story in the collection is
“The Story of the Fisherman.”
In it, an old man slogs through a hard day
of work, with nothing to show for it.
After casting his net many times, he draws
up a bottle of brass with a heavy lead stopper
stamped with the seal of a dead sultan.
When he opens the bottle, a plume of smoke
rises up and condenses into the form of a
massive ‘Efreet, an evil jinni, so big his
head is inside the clouds.
At first the jinni, having been trapped in
the bottle for 1,800 years, wants to kill
the fisherman.
But the old fisherman is clever.
He challenges the jinni to show him how it
was possible for such a magnificent, powerful
being to fit in such a small vessel.
Apparently very vain, the jinni turns back
into smoke and enters the bottle little by
little until the fisherman can seal it up,
once again trapping the Jinni.
After some negotiation the two come to a compromise—if
the fisherman releases him the jinni will
not only let the fisherman live, but will
grant him one service.
Once freed, the jinni leads the man to a hidden
lake in the desert where he is able to capture
the most exquisitely colored fish.
The rare fish make the fisherman a very prosperous
man.
Another important tale is “The Story of
the Merchant and the Jinnee.”
This version tells the story of a merchant
who rests under a tree, eating dates, when
he carelessly tosses a pit aside.
An angry jinni appears, sword drawn, claiming
the pit had struck and killed his son (remember,
jinni cannot be seen by humans in their natural
form).
Before he slays the man, he agrees to give
the merchant a year to get his affairs in
order.
A year passes, and the merchant returns to
the same spot under the tree and awaits his
death.
While sitting there three sheiks stumble upon
him one by one, each deciding to wait with
the doomed man.
When the jinni finally appears the sheiks
strike a bargain—they will each tell the
entity a story.
If one of the stories pleases the jinni, he
will relinquish one third of his claim on
the merchant’s life.
Luckily, each story impresses the jinni and
the merchant survives.
In the early 18th century, Antoine Galland,
a French archeologist and scholar was the
first person to translate the arabic collection
into a European language.
He procureda 3 or 4 volume manuscript from
the Eastern Mediterranean region of Levant,
dated between the 14th and 15th century.
The translation of these volumes became a
12-volume series published between 1704-1717
under the title The Thousand and One Nights,
Arab stories translated into French [Les mille
et une nuits, contes arabes traduitsen francais].
Despite containing only 280 nights, the series
was a hit.
For nearly a century, this version became
the main text for subsequent translations
and ironically, in 1814 Galland’s French
text was translated back to Arabic, while
the original Arabic source faded into obscurity.
Besides becoming the most commonly translated
version for many years, Galland’s text gave
the world something else—the stories of
Aladdin and Ali Baba.
He added these to the collection from oral
versions reportedly told to him by a monk
from Syria.
Both stories have no direct Arabic source.
The title Arabian Nights’ Entertainments
was first given to The Thousand and One Nights
collection by an anonymous Grub street English
translator of Galland’s version in 1706.
Arguably, part of the reason all of the versions
of The Thousand and One Nights became instant
sensations is because Europeans hoped to gain
some insight into the lands they had colonized.
Despite being sensationalized and exaggerated
to say the least, the stories were seen as
a window into foreign cultures.
In 1840, Edward William Lane, published the
first direct Arabic to English edition based
on an Egyptian version of the stories.
At Lane’s request, this Arabic version was
corrected and annotated by Sheikh Muhammad
al-Tantawi who helped translate the challenging
Middle Arabic words for more easy conversion
to English.
Lane’s version also included detailed research
notes on Arabic culture as well as illustrations.
In some Islamic traditions today, the jinn
are said to still roam the Earth, hidden from
humans.
And among some people, it is believed that
jinn are the cause of mental illness.
Hallucinations, epilepsy, and other conditions
are said to be the work of jinn.
When one considers that jinn are part of Muslim
religious tradition it’s understadable that
people would think this.
Much in the same way other religions conceptualize
demonic possession, a jinni occupying a human’s
body is one explanation for seemingly uncontrollable
behavior.
The word “genie” is an Anglicanized version
of the French word [Génies] first used by
Galland in 1706, a term itself borrowed from
the Latin word “genius” referencing a
supernatural guardian spirit.
The first reference of the genie granting
three wishes also appeared in Galland’s
text, in his rendition of “The Story of
the Fisherman”.
In that story, the jinni explains that he
initially thought about granting the person
who freed him from the bottle “three demands”
every day.
Since then, the three demands or wishes have
become a common jinn trope, even appearing
the first time a jinni appears in film.
The iconic Genie portrayed by Robin Williams
in Disney’s 1992 Aladdin is a hybrid of
all these iterations.
However, this time the jinni retains some
control over the three wishes he must grant,
giving Aladdin stipulations, including that
he cannot wish for more wishes.
From spiritual being to comical cartoon—that’s
quite a journey.
Jinn have shown up in traditions and stories
since the pre-Islamic Arabic world, but it
wasn’t until a few stories were translated
in the 18th century, that these beings were
popularized.
They’re more than just some blue guy trapped
in a lamp who grants wishes.
They’re powerful, intellectual entities
whose stories are woven into ancient Islamic
culture—and, yes, also capable of changing
the direction of your life in an instant.